welcome everybody to the h3 podcast live
today's episode is sponsored by stitch
Fixman hellofresh & Seek next Wednesday
is our first live show and by live I
mean SuperDuper live it's a live
broadcast from a live show super excited
we are gonna be joined by your boy post
Malone during the word live so I'm super
excited thank you very much if you have
questions for post Malone leave them on
the subreddit there's a thread there
there's also a thread there for Bob
Saget which we're having on a week from
today so if you have questions for post
more on Wednesday or Bob Saget on Friday
please leave them on the subreddit and
but enough about what to be let's talk
about our to come let's talk about what
be now because today's guest is the
extremely talented a researcher video
producer director filmmaker and
all-around great dude and good friend of
ours the illustrious and wonderful
vsauce3 also known as Jake Roper thank
you thank you that was a very nice
introduction let's stop [ __ ] around
all the time tell me about the model 3
you guys everybody who watch the show
knows that I'm like a huge Elon fanboy
there's only been like 2000 model threes
made and somehow you got in early enough
yeah got that thing like right away do
you know how early in the line you were
I don't know I'm not sure I mean I
waited in line did you guys physically
wait in line for the model 3 yeah I
don't even have a reservation
Wow and that's thanks for watching I was
their day of stood in line
what I thought you did it online they
made you ask to actually stay in line
well if you wanted higher priority than
you my interest which was exciting
because you've seen like Apple launches
and things like that the lineup forever
this is for like a car and no one's ever
driven and people were lining up so tell
me about that experience of being there
in line it was really neat how long was
the line it wasn't too long I think it
was probably in line for maybe an hour
an hour and a half but everyone's just
so excited and they had a bunch of tests
loaners came in with like their model
X's Model S's and we're showing them off
to pee
online it was really nice it sounds fun
yeah there's camaraderie between Tesla
boys oh sure I wave
I do the table wave no one ever waves
back sometimes that's story my wife yeah
there's camaraderie between me and
everyone I don't know about if it's
reciprocal yeah so the model 3 yeah good
thing after this we can go sit in it if
you want bro I need to but I love it so
I had a Model S yeah I was very
fortunate I had a Model S I sold that
once I got the model three because the
model 3 was less expensive a little bit
smaller yeah and it just feels like the
future whereas when I first got in the
Model S it's like oh this the future nay
not anymore the model 3 is fantastic
well what's what's not future
what's more future about the model 3 I
mean it's little things like the display
is incredibly fast the whole system is
immediate it's like you can just swipe
around like oh it feels more future than
s feel slow right yeah and the
minimalist design I really love like
minimalist modern design so it's just so
clean beautiful there's still things
that need to be fixed but in my mind the
only things that need to be fixed
our software not really hardware
definitely and I love it I like the fact
that it has more range than what my
previous car did and and it's it's not
significantly smaller but it feels
smaller it's not like a book that I'm
driving down the road right so I'm a big
fan I would highly recommend it I saw
model 3 on the road for the first time I
slowed down I was like man you know um
yeah the Model S is really like a boat
like Ice Cube
I can't even park it because like I
don't know where it starts or begins and
I'm always it's super wide yeah I when
my lease is up I definitely want to get
the three and she put in your
reservation do y it cuz if I still have
the car for another two years
oh then maybe don't put in your
reservation like I'm hoping that I'll be
able to get one by then you will I mean
the well I'm not gonna say you will I
don't know one who knows Elon time is on
a totally different plane of existence
than human being time right so who knows
they were supposed to be making like
five thousand cars every week by this
point yeah not yeah but I would just I
mean here's the thing that's cool about
it I feel like I'm just a spokesman for
Tesla Tesla if you're watching please
just give me a car yeah for free yeah
that'd be nice and everyone here you
Ethan shredder no don't be so right and
your hypothetical but it's a diamond oh
yes
so it's a thousand-dollar reservation
right and then you can get it back if
you decide you don't want the car so I
don't really see what the downside I
think the Malta Theory's a little too
flashy for me too I like that really you
think it's flashier than the other s did
I mean say I meant strike that I meant s
oh that is a little too flashy it is it
makes me feel like I should be more
important than I am it's just like I
feel like a phony when I Drive one of
those cars was just like it's like it
really shows what its gonna because it's
like the normal or it's a normal car
more affordable and it's got all the
cool features like and this would be
reached to really surprised me about it
even though the ones that you can only
get her like the most high-end model
right they started 35,000 the ones you
can get now are basically 50,000 55,000
which is still relatively inexpensive
compared to other cars in its league but
it's still not as cheap as just a normal
car but it's like going in there yeah
but even for a $35,000 car the
differences between the one that I have
in the one that will be the mass-market
version is not that great and just
seemed like wow this is a lot of car for
that much money and the fact that you
charge it like a phone blows my mind
yeah it's amazing
how's the acceleration it's pretty good
no it's not enough it's good enough I
mean my face isn't gonna melt off but
that's okay I come you don't need that
okay yeah this is okay but it's also a
thousand pounds lighter I believe than
the s so it feels really quick a little
more responsive yeah and the turns feel
really tight sometimes I'm trying to
make like a u-turn on the S and I'm like
any other car mm-hm and I it feels like
you're riding a boat like you have so
much space you make a u-turn there's
oncoming traffic and also no making a
three-point turn and a middle of a busy
intersection because I couldn't perform
a simple u-turn this segment of
firstworldproblems is brought to you so
angry
having us such an expensive car I know
it doesn't even turn itself around on a
u-turn
come on Ilan it does Park it so it does
that is actually really nice of shitty
I'm kind of upset with you on
you started here when I got that car
I was promised autopilot and all these
great features you say for full
self-driving yeah no not just autopilot
2.0 which still hasn't been updated
beyond the basic one that you started
with yeah I mean it's on relative parity
I think two ought to put autopilot 1.0
but it will get better I mean we got
Auto wipers guys ry person can already
take me everyone's just like alright
I'll get over it yeah all right
Tesla driving I know you were able to
but I hate just you were able to sell
the Model 3 or s oh yeah it sold like
immediately really really nice what did
you get a good price for it yeah I mean
the thing is I just wanted it to cover
the cost of the model 3 so I didn't
really care you didn't lose out I did
yeah that's but then my insurance
payments are much lower oh yeah cost of
ownership in general is just lower which
is nice for me god bless you know trying
to save money alright thank you for
sharing that experience yep I'll see you
next and next on chapter 2 of Elon Musk
oh did you get a boring company
flamethrower now I'm just like coming
across like some out-of-touch dude who
just spends money on stupid things is
that a yes I did I regret not buying one
you should I think it's sold out it is
sold out so I don't know who knows we
were talking about it I was like when
people get it everybody will know
there's gonna be all these lunatic
youtubers running around with yeah
flamethrowers then there's the whole
talk about is it technically a
flamethrower because the flame needs to
be a certain distance long outside of
like after the nozzle and it's not
really it's like a flamethrower in the
terms of that it's like a weed burner
it's a weed burner we Berta that's been
attached to a retrofitted airsoft gun
but the reason I purchased it one cuz
it's fun but to like I actually really
like the boring company's idea and this
is how they raise capital and like
awareness so if I can be if I have like
500 bucks to spend sure god buzz just
helped a billionaire with another
company yeah that thing could be a
collectible someday I won't be surprised
it's just a fun thing yeah I don't know
I don't know I don't like to probably
reenact
[ __ ] yeah sorry
well yeah I'm gonna bring everything in
sight um house first that'd be a fun
video I really just want to I want to
turn into Sigourney Weaver's character
from aliens that's my goal oh my god
imagine the cosplay wow did you not put
that on silent I put mine on airplane
mode well I respect you is that then
that's Dan oh my god son of a gun dang
it Dan I that is horrible I hate that
setting right this is why your parents
divorced and this is not approved I
don't know if that's true Danny's
parents divorcing anything he's crying
to it all right you just moved back here
from New York right uh yeah you were
working for beam yes how did ya I mean
how was everything I know many people
heard the news that beam was disbanded
canceled axed kiboshed I don't know why
I'm being more like Ben well how yeah
well I'm just curious how first of all
how are you you you made a big life
change recently yeah I mean I'm fine I
don't ever regret the decisions that I
make generally because it was a learning
experience like did it turn out
successfully for all his purposes no but
I learned a lot from it I like the fact
that I was living both in New York and
LA which is like a very nice thing to do
is kind of fun pretty sweet it was sweet
it's kind of difficult though all the
time because when you're trying to be
creative like focusing all of your
energy on to one thing gets a little bit
diffused when you have something else
that you're supposed to be focusing on
right I'm sure you guys know that just
from all the projects that you work hard
to keep that up but I'm I mean I think
it's fine I like the fact that we could
we were given the opportunity to do what
we wanted to do we didn't really fulfill
that but I have no
real hard feelings or bad feelings like
the only thing I I was a little upset
about was how it was handled because
basically we're gonna tell you and then
hey in two weeks we're like immediately
basically everything's changed
there was no ramp up period - it was
just this immediate turn over all this
so tell me about like how how did you
get the news like how did it happen you
said it happened immediately right yeah
so I woke up to a BuzzFeed article you
didn't know everything was great I had a
notion or - just from my talks with
people that something was up I didn't
think it was going to be as drastic as
what had happened hmm
I mean my mind it was like Casey's gonna
just do his own thing and that's fine
and we're still going to run as we were
for the rest of this year right and find
our own footing that wasn't the case
obviously I found out it was actually so
it was my birthday was the day with
everything was announced so I was like
all these text messages and they were
all were like happy birthday what
happened to being so that I googled it
and there was this BuzzFeed article
because it hadn't been announced to the
company yet how does that have well
Casey's vlog about it he accidentally
made public before it was supposed to
and that then triggered the BuzzFeed
article to come out Wow Wow and then
Casey pulled his video but buzz we
didn't pull their article found out
either through Casey's accidental vlog
or the BuzzFeed article before they were
actually told how did you feel when you
found out so you were reading beam is
being shut down yeah I was like I woke
up did you believe it we like are you
sure cuz I don't know I believed it yeah
I believed it it was it was an
interesting experience because I was
just I was in LA when that happened so I
was just talking to everybody in New
York while they were going like oh we're
going up to find out if we still have
jobs I mean everyone basically
everyone's like offered jobs and if they
decided today it was up to them yeah not
maybes in there
I think only three people on the team
were actually let go outside of myself
Casey and Matt like three full time
members were actually like oh everyone
else out of the other like 25 people
we're still offer auditioning yeah so
they handled I mean they gave people the
opportunity to like hey you can still
grow and build whatever you want to
within CNN if that's what you choose
that's nice but for me didn't really
make sense anymore
yeah were you were you relieved or were
you sad by the news
I'm always sad when you don't get to do
what you want like when you're not in
charge of your own destiny is always
kind of a sad feeling for me but what
did I plan come April when my lease was
up in New York I'd planned to move back
full-time here and just when they needed
me fly in and help with productions or
whatever but really take a back seat
which is always kind of the plan I
wasn't supposed to be part of the news
team forever the idea was like KC and I
helped set the tone for what the news
team is and then after three months we
move on to working on other projects
under the beam banner and we never got
to that point so that was the main thing
we had a lot of ideas for things that we
wanted to create together that we never
got to yeah and that's always sad seeing
ideas die right why do you think that it
didn't work out well I'm also one for
dramatic purposes to to think about what
I'm actually led to say um I mean I
honestly what Casey said in his vlog
about him just kind of disappearing from
the entire team is is a large part of
that and there's two sides of it I think
one people were disappointed because
they were kind of promised that hey
you're gonna be making videos with Casey
and that's a lot of pressure to put on
to one person yeah like hey Casey like
run this whole thing manage everything
yeah it's like okay well I could just do
my own stuff and be more successful at
that right and I can do anything that I
want and not have to rely on other
people and then from that some people
took that as like oh we've been
abandoned and they just shut down others
kind of what were that like I'm gonna
make something myself but obviously
having Casey is like a figureheads a
very important thing to have especially
when you're trying to gain audience for
something and with that not there I just
think that it seemed less of an
incentive to keep it going
Casey wasn't really involved it wasn't
in the videos towards the end of the
rodeo yeah he was just saying I guess
was he just not I mean I don't wanna
like confusion about the identity of
them yeah like he was there to kind of
direct us creatively and he wasn't and
I'm not trying to put the blame on him I
think like I was thinking about this a
lot and even seeing it and experiencing
it I do a similar thing right it's
easier to be like okay I'm just gonna
separate myself from this so if it fails
it's not really my fault like I was
leaving a part of it right and there is
a lot of pressure where you know the
dude
going from making videos by himself
doing anything he wants myself now you
have a team of 10 people they have to be
in charge and CNN's like okay this is
the new vice news now go get it yeah we
didn't really have which I think there
was a lot of just miss communications
where I remember I was actually we could
go last year that I started at Beeman
was just Casey and I and this other guy
and we were just making stuff for like
trying to make things that was really
really fun because was just us creating
things didn't worry about anyone else
yeah and then like a month later where
he's like hey we just hired nine new
people we have to figure out how these
cogs fit into this machine that hadn't
been built yet so we're trying to build
it around the pieces that were inside
where we should have kind of been doing
it the other way so I get it like it was
just a lot of stress and pressure and so
I get it
well it was a cool experience um really
cool videos it was a it's a shame I feel
like because I felt the last video you
guys made about cryptocurrency yeah I
remember and I was like man I felt like
kind of just I don't know I felt like a
little nostalgia already for it being
gone and I really I was like this was so
cool this was a great video and I wanted
I kind of felt like you guys were maybe
just starting to hit your stride a
little bit I think we had honestly in my
mind once the pressure of like Casey
need to be involved was gone everyone
took these kind of breath was like oh we
can just do what we want now we're not
trying to aim for someone else's
guidelines or someone else's vision
we're just gonna do what we want yeah
and I even did that I mean I'm guilty as
well where I kind of took a back seat it
was like I'm just like you guys do this
but then with that crypto mining piece I
was like you know what actually enjoy
this like Jack who was in the video with
me let's just go make this ourselves
mm-hmm and I think if I had done more of
that then maybe things might be
different I don't really know but I
didn't I was never when I was hired I
was never supposed to be on camera right
and that's what really appealed to me
was like I'm gonna be behind care and
help run things right and not have to be
this person who's dictating and
directing and like moving it through it
was a different thing yeah it was a
whole new thing yeah but it's fine I
will our title was director of
production yeah but I learned a lot from
it and I'm happy for that a great
experience yet about anything like I
learned a lot I met a lot of new people
that I really liked and we got to even
make a video together yeah real baby
Dasia so I don't I'm not upset about it
I feel bad for the I mean also I'm very
fortunate I had two jobs I was doing
Vsauce and this at the same time so I
lost one job oh no what am I gonna do
I'll just move back to LA I guess I'm
continuing my other job to be able to
focus on that more do you feel inspired
at all to continue the journalistic
approach now that you've had a taste for
it not at all huh it was interesting
this again why news has never been my
thing I don't I think it's interesting I
don't particularly like being involved
in it because you can't control the
story as much it has to be exactly
what's there in front of you needing to
portray it as realistically and honestly
as possible hopefully but when it comes
to like what I do I'd be says I can
create a world and like show it to you
through my own lens right anymore that
rative it's more filmmaking versus like
a documentary capturing things right so
I mean it's all right well I'm sad
because I love that video it's like I
want more videos doing investigating
[ __ ] I mean I wouldn't hate CNN if
you're watching this but you probably
are not getting money at yeah an eon and
while you're watching - were the we all
need model threes a damn it and two jobs
by the way how was where was it you guys
went to Iceland or Greenland Iceland so
in this video if you guys haven't seen
it you guys went to Iceland where is it
the world's biggest crypto farm
according to the company that has the
crypto mind it is the largest kryptonite
in the world but they don't know the
operation was so crazy because the the
reason they set it up was because of the
cold weather and they would save money
on cooling their massive mining
operation so they literally just suck
air in from the outside and blow it over
there massive servers yeah I was I was
so cool to see well is it the whole
thing like they say there's a few things
like oh the electricity is more
economical I remember how they said it
the cold air they can just like pull it
in siphon it out but then also the
government of Iceland is a lot more
agreeable to crypto currencies where's
like China place like I've been cracking
down on it right
Iceland isn't as severe I have to say
when I saw that I'm like this is kind of
messed up because in a crypto is I've
read I don't remember the exact number
so I'm not gonna say it but crypto
mining is actually you
like a substantial amount of electricity
across the eight point two percent of
all electricity generated and said why
for litter for like I don't know like
just what are they doing they're just
it's literally just like burning power
is there an end to the mining like is
all that computing power going into
something useful I mean eventually
eventually there's only so much of the
different kind of like crypto currencies
or the old coins whatever you have that
you can mine so eventually there won't
be anymore to mine mm-hmm but that's
quite a ways away but like what is the
computing doing cuz they're like burning
power computing and crunching data on
something yes it's something useful or
is it just burning energy to this whole
discussion now is that the blockchain
the basic infrastructure that operates
crypto currencies could be used for
other things it could be used for
infrastructure it could be used for like
medical practices Crowley doors no yeah
but I'm not entirely sure this I still
have we're actually planning a whole
series I've ended up caning about it was
like basically let's learn about this
because I don't understand it fully yeah
I'm just like what cuz you always say
blockchain like what is that though
watching though what does it mean it's a
digital ledger what does that mean I
don't know Seinfeld care they're
crunching algorithms that solve nothing
essentially right I I am NOT okay we
haven't gone that I don't know you make
that serious well I probably sound
really ignorant to some people yeah I
just I don't know the whole thing is so
crazy the whole Bitcoin thing are you
invested at all I do have a little bit
not much you're doing all these things I
might as well try right
but yeah don't don't try it there's a
lot quantity on VidCon and I don't care
how much I'm just curious when you're
invested oh yeah
so not Bitcoin yeah that's a sucker's
bound all about ëthere iam and garlic
coin garlic oil dogecoin yeah Kayne coin
what about football coin super coin Oh
big
put my own tire hedge fund that doesn't
exist into FUBU hell ya know things like
aetherium litecoin yeah Ripple
extra quest Network iota just like those
are all the few things okay
diverse portfolio very nice well it's
more of I like to think was like you
just play little seeds cuz who knows
what's going to be the next Bitcoin if
we ever get to that kind of sure level
again yeah you might as well just
because it's like some of those things
are 30 cents was like cool I can buy 10
now that's not really a huge loss of
Mayan yeah we have a friend who got
involved actually two friends that we
know gumball like real early they
invested like 2,000 bucks maybe I think
it was two years ago they said and like
etherium they're like up to a hundred
thousand bucks and I you find it
interesting it's a girl yeah it's kind
of like a lot of times you don't really
see female ela I cannot believe you just
made that channel we're not allowed to
make I mean no I'm proud of that
we have a girlfriend who's if you're
watching I think she's giving a shout
personally I'm just like dude take that
money and wrong that's always the fear
right is like if you pull out now like
haha but it could be it's like the hold
but I don't know it just seems like
glorified gambling to me I don't
understand it though so don't judge me I
mean I have no real knowledge about
markets or anything like that the only
piece of advice that I've ever listened
to when it comes to this stuff is that
whatever you invest should be something
that you're willing to lose right and
then the second thing is once so for me
once I made enough money that covered
how much I invested I pulled out that
amount so I didn't lose any money
great so whatever a little bit amount of
money I have left it's just like it's
fun money it's funny right funny money
I don't know fun months when he wears
chuck-e-cheese bucks chucky cheese bucks
that has real value it did actually that
actually would be a cool thing like how
much is it
chucky cheese how thing like tickety
sauce 3 boom it's gonna Tommy's bucks
equals one Bitcoin or one bottle three
are one three so I've noticed now since
you've moved back to LA that you are
seem to be much more active on vsauce3
oh nice fate bag
you vaping I was here yeah that was like
you were key or something it kind of
looks like well maybe a sex toy but also
it kind of looks like a nice pebble that
you would throw across the lake with
your hands and I should just say for
those watching at home this is a just
water vapor there's no drugs in this
yeah right thanks for the disclaimer do
people know yet
it's not cannabis is that what we call
it no it was funny I wish I saw this
you're talking about our new video the
return of white man face I assume don't
say them work what are you serious
weirdly coincidental I did some research
before I got here um I just saw in our
subreddit now this posted an article
right or like from two weeks ago and
that video was posted like a month ago
where they used marijuana and the title
of the article and I was just like but
he said what happened Asians like them
and others don't say that word anymore I
don't know what to believe my whole life
is like so you're asking a question
before are you happy to be more focused
now on vsauce3 now that beam has met its
demise am I happy let's start with that
part of the question what is seven grams
uh so I am happier to be here I mean
Michael's also now back full time little
legit Papa bless cuz he is my dad um you
know cherish me out just to go on a
little tangent he's younger than me is
he
Michael is younger than me is that make
how are you
he's the same age you get this image
okay but he's 32 okay where is he 33 I
think he's a little younger than me
one's your birth but even if he's the
same age that's weird and I'm gonna get
to the bottom of June June June
Michael's is January he's 20 seconds
he's younger than me 1986 I don't know
that just seems to 5 because he's like
that yeah you think that is the glasses
the beard the whole look anyway I'm
sorry yes yeah so I'm excited cuz we're
both here he likes is not doing his tour
at the moment he's not doing mine field
so we're just in the office every day
that's cool II like I want to make more
things I felt and I still feel to a
degree that I've been creatively dry so
and it's hard difficult it's difficult
to get back into that kind of like
motivation like I'm gonna make stuff yay
yeah but being there is really nice I
like being around like our employees and
like Michael and all that stuff so I
want to make more things I'm working on
some interesting stuff I think oh well I
love like the energy I love the vibe in
your guys's office you have this
wonderful warehouse yeah where you all
work from it's really cool mm-hmm and
we're also two blocks down the street
from corridor digital which is nice so
we get to see like other creators who
dat what is more additional Oh would
highly recommend they do kind of like an
evolution of what Freddy W was doing we
all kind of like Brian of the same
literally the same office to YouTube
channel yeah the quarter they make like
incredible like these beautiful visual
effects heavy videos they're really
really talented
oh so yeah off to check them out it may
shock you that it's already been 30
minutes and that means I am blown away
because this conversation is so silky
smooth we're gonna run to a commercial
real fast and we will be back after a
short break because I have so much more
I want to ask you and there's so much
more to know stay tuned do not go
anywhere thank you - hello fresh we're
sponsoring this episode of the H Street
podcast we have teamed up with hello
fresh to offer our audience
$30 off your first week of deliveries
when you go to hellofresh calm and use
the offer code h 3 podcast one word I
love Hello fresh it's my favorite day of
the flippin week you get this package
it's frigerator it's cool it's got
proteins vegetables every single
ingredient you need to cook a beautiful
homemade meal and it shows up right at
your door
it's such a fun service it solves so
many problems you need to go shopping
you need to think what to cook right
it's all there and one of the annoying
things is like when you want to cook
Civic nice meal you go to the market and
it's like you need to Leafs of cilantro
and the markets like well here's five
pounds that's your only option so now
you get exactly the right proportion and
you don't have to think about it
everything comes pre-measured another
label and you know exactly what you need
they offer a wide variety of chef
curated recipes that change on a weekly
basis recently I have enjoyed the
chicken sausage pizza with fresh oregano
look at this look at this pizza you know
I'm a pizza boy and this was off the
chain and it's super easy to make the
way they you have exact instructions
everything is labeled measured you just
want to follow the steps yeah they've
got these wonderful little info sheets
with lots of bright colors and all the
instructions you would need and also
they don't include crayons but I love
drawing on that well the food's cooking
they also have all these taco recipes
the last time we had was a pork and
poblano are you freaking que me a little
spicy a little savory oh my god I would
never make this myself you know I just
go home and eat chips or something awful
like that cuz I'm to like I don't have
time but they show up at the door and oh
it's the best day of the week guys it's
so fresh it's so easy to cook it's
delicious it's bounced and it's a
wonderful dinner for less than $10 a
meal feel confident with the simple
recipes outlined on pictures with step
by step instructions if you can't even
boil an egg like my mother I love her
but she one time boiled eggs and she
walked upstairs forgot and the eggs
exploded and we're literally on the roof
like ten feet ahead my mom that joke
about not cooking egg you know but a
boil egg is real in her case she has
made hello fresh and made a delicious
meal so if she can do it you can too so
here's the deal go to hell afresh calm
and use the code h3 podcast one word and
get 30 bucks off your first order of
week of deliveries so thank you to hell
afresh for sponsoring this episode of
the h3 podcast next up we have got
stitch
you can tell when a guy's got style he
always looks great and seems confident
and he's ready for anything anything
well that takes a certain skill set not
all of us were born with and but now
there's an easy way to look better and
let me tell you about stitch fix meant
that's true some guys just have swag
it's the same for women too some ladies
have swag it's not some like look we
takes a lot of effort it's like who
cares sometimes you just want to write
not worry about what you're wearing well
some people have swag in other areas and
some people have swag in other areas I
felt really sad saying like maybe you're
a real funny dude and maybe you just
don't know how to dress yourself but
with stitch fix they fill in you know
you can they fill in that part they're
your virtual girlfriend your virtual mom
wrapped up you don't have to bug them
like it's just someone ladies paid to
help you out so here's the deal about
what stitch fix is it's a new way to
shop for clothes and it's unbelievably
simple you go to stitch fix calm and
answer some questions about your sizes
what styles you like and how much you
want to spend stitch fix has clothes for
every guy and his style not just one
type of look they've got it all in fact
I have a friend he's a motorcycle ER
he's crazy dude he came out with the I
don't know I'm sure they've got leather
jackets with flames and [ __ ] if that's
what you're into but they've got
everything is my point your personal
stylist then uses your preference and
other information you enter to select
brand new clothes just for you the items
are delivered right to your door you try
them on and you only pay for what you
keep just send anything you don't want
back and shipping is free both ways
that's right buster get your fix on
demand and sign up to receive scheduled
shipments guys of all shapes I love that
all shapes and sizes and budgets
relatable exactly defining your new
style starts with stitch that
so guys Dan has been rockin stitch fix
and I think I honestly but when Dan
started I was like I know about this guy
once he started getting stitched fixed
he's got like this sweater that he just
he wears every day it's getting kind of
weird they sent him this sweater that he
loves it so much that is getting weird
and that can be you too so try them out
today you've got nothing to lose so go
now to stitch fix calm slash h3 you get
25% off when you keep all five items in
your box
that's stitch fixed calm I'm / h3 to get
started a stitch fix calm / h3 thank you
for sponsoring cuz then finally we've
got seed geek I freaking love me some
seat geek you have heard of all these
various websites where you go and buy
tickets and you get ripped off by all
these suckers see geeks not one of those
guys in fact they're the opposite
because when you go online you want to
buy tickets to a concert a post Malone
show a Kings game whatever Kings I don't
know why I said Kings Lakers whatever
you're into sporting event Dodgers they
give you a view from the seat and they
rate the seat on how good of a deal
you're getting on that seat so you know
exactly where you're sitting you know
exactly what kind of deal you're getting
there's no flippin surprises dude and
it's just such a great wonderful service
if you want to go to any event I
recommend seeking ten out of ten times
that's what I use and that's what you
should use uh my dude for example my dad
they hooked up tickets for me and my dad
when we went to it was the world's
Dodgers World Series we were like right
behind home plate and they just they had
they just did that out of the kindness
of their heart for my dad on his
birthday that's not related to how good
their services but just more of a
testament to what great dudes they are
so they you get a 1 to 10 score on each
seat to let you know how good of a deal
you're getting the Green is good at the
red is bad
we got a hookup for you guys at home
they want to see a show go to event
whatever use code h3h speak for 20 bucks
off your first order just click the me
tab on the app and enter code h3h3 for
$20 off click the link in the
description too
download the app so go to the link of
description and use code h3h3 for 20
bucks off your first seat geek order
love seat geek guys if you are in the
market for anything of our sponsors of
support please help I don't I'm that it
makes sense that sentence what I mean to
say if you're in the market for a new
grocery list a new clothing line in your
closet or a ticket yes that's exactly
what I met through an event please
consider supporting our sponsors because
they help support the show and make it
possible with that being said let's get
right back into it
welcome everybody back to the three
podcasts before we want to break you had
mentioned that you were creatively
blocked or like bankrupt just because we
watched one of your recent videos about
a video about making a video or was it a
video about not making it yeah yeah but
specifically the one about my being
stuck yeah which I loved and I think
anyone on YouTube would be like that's
way too or later it was tell me a bit
about like when you're creative really
blocked yeah I would like how do you
what do you do like how do you break
through some my mentality on it and
again this just pertains to me I don't
know how this works for other people but
I
you can't force it I always find like
the more you try to be creative the less
you actually are it's one of those
moments where like you're just listen to
music and it hits you like yes that's
what I could do okay if it's it so I
have to what I've been doing actually
the past week has just been 3d printing
objects to see what I could do with them
and then also just listening to this
audio library that we use and just like
shuffling through it and when I hear a
song I add it to a playlist you just
there so I've like million playlet
millions playlists for like videos I've
never made yet well you know this will
be good for like I made one playlist
which won't make any sense sounds weird
but it was called untitled a kidnapped
daughter video Wow so one more to that
one but I try and rescue my daughter
taking style who doesn't exist but one
day she will maybe I don't know anyway
it's just listening to music and like
zoning out because for me at least
I need a hear me
that's like motivates everything in my
life especially with videos because of
you listening to me okay great cameras
gonna go like this and this sounds like
the feeling of it is it's going to be
more about kind of like shapes like a
decison I want to do it on that so I
just need music but it's a process
there's no and this why we make video so
infrequently on Vsauce is because it
takes a while to find the topic that you
want to talk about and then how do you
talk about it it needs to be done in a
way that is unique to degree and can
feel like this full meal and I need to
understand the topic better than anybody
because it has to be infallible
everything that I say needs to be exact
so just I don't know I'm hopefully but
well I mean I don't know like I think we
Evan flow right like I'm sure you guys
have gone through yeah I mean we talked
about this before we're like yeah
because I can't even do anything man
like I feel like I'm being forced to
make videos yeah and I never want to be
in that position and the guilt that I
feel for not making content is because I
know that there are lovely people who do
want to watch it yeah and that's but at
this is I don't know I didn't actually
think I was in the car right here and
interject whatever you want please
because I could just talk forever for it
did is that I find myself thinking that
being like creating or making things is
an amazingly selfish act like why am i
doing it I'm doing because I want people
to like me that's the reason I make
things because I want them to see what's
in my mind and today and to agree with
it or to like find some semblance of
themselves in it and that's why I make
things I don't make things just for them
I make them so they understand me and so
that they like me that's the reason that
I create anything and I think that's
potentially true for lots of people
there's a lot of artists who say I
create for the purpose of sharing do you
think that anyone can possibly actually
feel that or do you think they're
deluding themselves into thinking like
hey I'm doing something I'm helping the
world but really they're just kind of I
think that you can have that kind of
noble cause mentality but there's always
that you're also kind of just doing it
for yourself which nothing is bad like
you should do things for yourself I
don't think the two are contradicting
like for you you may think like that but
still for the viewers they get a lot
from it and maybe you did it because you
just want them to like you but they
still you made them have a better day I
don't know yeah it does have to be
siloed it's not all black and white
there's this really lovely gray area in
the middle
but I I don't I just have this thought
sometimes and this is a kind of moving
to a higher level thing where I always
feel like I'm never going to be
satisfied like in anything that I do and
I think that's also a driver for why you
keep making things is nothing is going
to be good enough there's never gonna be
a point we're making video that was the
best video I ever made I'm done that's
kind of what Jordan peterson said when
he was here is that like the purpose of
life is to live on the edge of like the
black and white a big chaos in the order
I think if you ever are truly satisfied
well it's fine then good for you but
that's where growth stops right because
if you're just stagnant then we're
listening like that's it's not a
negative thing to be that way just that
I mean I don't know how what I would do
if I was that way like I remember when I
was you know like stuck on a couch for
three months I couldn't do anything I
was like I'm worthless I have no purpose
I can't make anything that when you were
battling cancer yeah this is like I'm a
piece of garbage like I can't do
anything and I no motivation to do
anything in that the fear was will I
ever get out of this well I always feel
this way and will I just be complacent
with what I have and not try to achieve
greater and it's not true greater in
terms of like the things that I own it's
achieved greater in terms of who I am
and the things that I can create I don't
know if that's just like very fluffy and
hoity-toity but no I think it makes
total sense you know I I've always kind
of been envious of people who can just
be satisfied and and like just happy
with living the life that they have and
like it's satisfying they come home
they're happy I don't know if that
actually exists but I'm sure it does
just some extent but I think it's rare
that there's somebody who's just like I
have a job I'm totally satisfied
I have no ambitions further than where I
am now and I just gonna live like this
for the rest of my days I think there's
probably some it's must be very ripping
and no one really looks at it like that
I think happiness is like in little
moments like no one is really like my
life is great not great go to work we'll
combine this like like I know I think of
like farmers or some [ __ ] but like real
impetus in life right no I think
actually I mean that those people
exist I do believe it to be rare but I
think eel is kind of right with that
where there are moments peponi I was
talking to my girlfriend about this
where you know she asked me like are you
happy like in this moment yes like with
you right now I am outside of this there
are things I'm like not happy about yeah
I am sad about but in this moment yes I
am happy but also it like it we're kind
of talking about when it comes to people
being satisfied it's like a grass is
always greener you know you're like
which I also feel like I love just be
satisfied and like have a home and a
family like a job that I go to from 9:00
to 5:00 but I assume that people in
those situations are also like man I
wish I could do anything that I want I
wish I could do like what Neal and Jake
do yeah like it's always better there's
always other side of the fence yeah no
100% it's the human condition doesn't
matter how great it is man you're always
you're always gonna be a whiny little
[ __ ] pretty much Obama's at home right
now I'm being like goddamn dude I wish I
could have wish I could I don't know one
more frankly but he's thinking about
something it reminds me of that there's
this great scene from the office when uh
Andy is like I wish somebody would tell
him I wish there was a way to know when
you're in the good old days and why
you're in what does it mean that you are
vsauce3 I've always I still understand
the whole Vsauce like not even the
hierarchy just like the what's going on
there what does it mean that you're a
Vsauce how are you guys all associated
um well we're all friends first buddies
yeah I think it's a similar way of
thinking about topics and a similar way
of expressing them like the way that we
do them it's packaged differently but I
think that the through line is always
similar what do you I mean I watch like
oh this feels like Vsauce I don't know
how to better explain it besides like
it's this feeling that we all try and
express in our content but it was really
we actually Michael and Kevin I talk
about this a lot where if we had made
these channels today they probably
wouldn't be named like Vsauce one two
and three they'd be probably different
names it was just that in the day you
named your second channel two third
channel three and that's why we did it
yeah I think it's just we all have a
similar way of viewing the world and
we're all just very curious about
similar topics we express them
I mean sorry I said the same thing twice
but to give examples you know you can
watch for what we do educational content
and they all feel varied and different
and we try and do ours differently than
how they do it and to us that's what
makes it Vsauce instead of like physics
girl or smarter every day it just has a
different feeling to it there's
definitely a delivery that you guys all
have this really like sharpen us way of
speaking where you just had pauses for
right that's what I meant but you guys
are you guys like also business partners
or do you guys just kind of a couple
dudes who like being associated I know
we're all business partner okay yeah so
we all work together we run the business
together
dude yeah it's like it's Michael's like
Michael created it like he's the top dog
but we all work together in a really
nice way that's cool you discussed like
each other's videos do if we have
questions like you know Kevin will call
me like anything about this we'll talk
about it or if like I have questions on
a script I'll send it to Michael by
talking about acceleration correctly
here like the past few days we've just
been all there we are
ela said I didn't mean to break you off
I just wanted to share this video or
this picture they want that the boy band
of science described you guys then
Michael was Michael wearing that sweater
on ironically did he just show up in
that sweater no his wife made him that
sweater he loves it he's wearing it
today actually yeah his wife made that
forum yeah we all worked here and I love
that like currently I've been my next
video is potentially gonna be about
impossible objects which are these like
really cool illusions like these 2d
illusions but I'm printing them in three
dimensions on a 3d printer but they need
to look 2d when you look at it but by
looking at in 2d it makes it look 3d so
that's been a fun challenge but I
basically just been showing all the ones
I print to my cake dude check this out
only I show him he's even look at his
certain angles like I take a bigger than
run over to his decimal look at this
well look at this anyway all these
things on his desk and
end up doing that for like an hour and
then I go wait I got to work again sorry
oh that's awesome so it's really fun
like I love you know I was in Michael's
wedding as one of his groomsmen like
we're just all really good friends well
how did you meet Michael did you attend
obviously you got bright yeah well I
guess it was grinder around at the I yet
I look grinders it sound so obscene
doesn't it it sounds like you're gonna
murder somebody it sounds like you're
just cool to me it just sounds like
you're grinding [ __ ] like grinder it's
like when you rub on another person in
such a way i Ryan I've never been sexual
so it's like things like you I mean
Grindr I mean I assume people do that I
guess that's why it exists I'm not
married yet seven or anything he invited
you to become a Vsauce how does it how
do you become a pea sauce dare you guys
looking for a Vsauce for or the sauces
is there enough sauce there's a there's
a good amount of sauce I think if we
ever get to make another channel it
might not be Vsauce Numerical it might
just be Vsauce kids or something right
right um we'd love to try and do
something where we help other creators
create similar and in scope I think to
what the vlogbrothers you would like
we're gonna give two thousand dollars or
something to all these different
creators and they can buy equipment like
we'd love to figure out some way to be
more hands-on with other science
communicators but not own any of what
they do but just like help them maybe
that's how we're involved but I met
Michaels so I met Michael and Kevin
because we all worked at Google together
oh wait Louie you worked at Google
before you were sauce yes you do there
Wow so we were all strategists so we
worked basically with brands and with
advertisers and with creators to help
them emphasize their content on the
platform and go through analytics
behaviors to notice so we did that
Michael was still doing Vsauce at the
time Kevin was doing Vsauce - and I was
working on a project called Space Lab
which was this really exciting project
where it was an initiative that YouTube
was doing where some kids would submit
science experiments and then one of them
would actually be sent to the
International Space Station to be
performed so I made all of the content
for that channel like hosting what would
go up to one of these kids experiments
would go up to the ISS just like you
said they were gonna send a kid up to
space I was like yeah
do I need a spaceship now you're good
competition so that's how I met Mike
like Michael and I sat next to each
other and I was working on Space Lab he
was still doing strategy and like Vsauce
when he could in his free time because
if he saw said that at that point wasn't
huge yet it maybe had like 200 300
thousand subscribers when it started
getting really big that became his
full-time job he's like listen Google
I'll still help you with stuff but
Vsauce is what I'm gonna focus on and I
started helping him edit some like da
episodes and stuff like that for his
channel right and he originally asked me
to be a channel has been around that
long oh yeah he's the inception pretty
much of Vsauce I mean when he started
was a gaming comedy channel like the
videos Mario far so that's what's so
nice about even the name Vsauce even
like with what your ears are h3h3
productions it could be anything
yeah it's not like we're like we make
video game comedy the channel oh my gosh
shucks well now we got to do that yeah
so I was working that Michael asked me
to be the channel manager and I kind of
was like what if I just did my own
channel so we worked together and we had
another guy Joey at the time he was
hosting too and I just wrote a bunch of
scripts in him to give him Michael
they're like these are great Google's
like a Jake's gonna do this do it so
that's kind of how it's done so cool
yeah so what happened to Joey where's he
or well because I noticed if you go to
vsauce3 mmm first video has Vsauce -
yeah who was Vsauce - when vsauce3 was
Vsauce - so he was basically the channel
when it first launched was this guy Joey
who made video game content myself and
then Kevin from Vsauce - okay because I
was still doing Space Lab full-time like
my Google stuff full-time so I couldn't
make all the content so Kevin would like
pitch in and make some videos make some
videos and then once I handed I gave
Space Lab off to Scientific American
once we did that like beginning of 2012
then I started doing Vsauce three
full-time cool so Joey stepped away
Kevin stepped away and was just me by
the way I understand you have a resume
of working on kids content do you know
that they're doing an open casting call
for Blue's Clues are they really open
casting call dude dude I was like I
could never be as good as Steve though
that's kind of my well dilemma I'm like
hey they says here's the casting call it
says we're looking for the perfect host
that is a comedy background natural
connect
with the camera and someone who will
empower the home viewer to feel
important respected and smart that's you
dude yeah I just gonna be like listen
guys I'm creatively bankrupt I can't
think of any ideas so today we're just
gonna eat nachos and watch a movie
erasers well do you play guitar sing or
juggle they're looking for a juggler
well I can juggle a song a dance that's
alright I can juggle the heck out of
anything well not anything but I did I
did do circus camp for quite a while I
can do flaming clubs circus camp yeah I
can do some fresh T camp basically well
I tell me about yeah so the school that
I went to we had a circus program
because our theatre director used to be
in the circus so we had a whole circus
program and at Circus camp I did circus
as like my arts thing and no little
strength I mean I can juggle I can do
tightrope dude I can jump through fire
hoops I don't know if I can I say these
things if I could do that today I don't
know I could do it when I was like 10
years old I was much more nimble then
and you got a flamethrower and I could
do it in throwers here is something that
I saw that was a real crack-up he
received a gift from YouTube recently
and they said happen to be a picture of
Vsauce 2 and then they sent me multiple
copies of what's the chronology of
receiving 5 coasters randomly and it
didn't they were included I like took it
out framed photo of not me
they were my comments and also my
channel name but not my face and then
they also sent five in the front of
these these sent those with a sharpie so
I could sign them to give to fans so
maybe one it could be a collector's item
Kevin however got that's the same photo
these for Kevin he got his - they just
no I never get answer yeah they emailed
my partner manager and she was very
apologetic and they sent me a new one
which is now hanging up in the CNN
office because I sorry YouTube I didn't
want it
yeah values that no but they were like
because they email me do you want this
said no so then they send me a photo of
it hanging up in one of their like edit
Suites mom but yeah always have this to
commemorate but it is perfect like I
mean I love YouTube they've we wouldn't
have careers without them but is this
kind of like this delinquency that they
have really top creators we love you
here's one that's totally not even you
because they would even like did you get
your pride all right it's almost like I
can't even get you all you Vsauce is
straight yeah this is probably him but
it's fine I love that so what's your
plan going forward what is your dream
project I'm curious because now the
beams out of the way you're back home
your focus on your own Chet yeah like
let's say in five years from now what
would you love to be working on in a
perfect world that's a great question I
mean five years ago I didn't even think
I'd be doing what I'm doing now so who
knows how the the landscape will change
I would love to make a movie I'd like to
make a feature-length movie would be
really nice
you want to write direct oh just direct
I think just direct it if I could like
help I'm not a great writer when it
comes with scripts I'm great at writing
for myself I don't know how good I am
providing for others so I'd like to
direct something I think would be really
neat and I'm trying to do more of that
like I'm currently working on a much
longer series much more expensive series
for a Vsauce hmm but I think really cool
that I can't talk too much about now but
soon people be able to see it that's
exciting cuz all independently no more
more info to be revealed later that's
good but all my videos like my most
expensive video ever made I think cost
like 3 grand or something like the home
alone one that one was insane you had
like a whole thank you house well no
what I didn't pay anything like that was
like what I was that was a brand deal
they built the set for me so I don't
have to invest anything like I think the
most expensive video I made was the
Muppets video and that was because I'd
like I hired a crew and stuff but I
would love to see what I could do with
an actual budget which hopefully this
thing that I'm working on will allow me
to do like what could
make with hundreds of thousands of
dollars yeah I don't know maybe
something good hopefully that's super
exciting but I love to do stuff like
that I'm trying to one thing that's
really important which actually I really
appreciate you guys for and I think you
handled it lovely is extending the brand
beyond one platform because we don't
control YouTube we have no idea what's
going to happen when they make changes
it affects us in a very significant way
beyond things like teddy fresh which
also exists outside of yourselves
which is super important if h3 were just
disappear tomorrow you still have this
one brand that isn't entirely tied to
you where's the same thing we tried to
be like the Curiosity Box like creating
products that can exist without us
having to always endorse them or promote
them right well that seems to be killing
it oh thank you yeah super cool - I love
what you guys put in it yeah I mean
that's just like a really fun thing to
do but again it it allows us to not only
be Vsauce allows us to do something
different and grow what we do like my
dream is always and I actually loved it
when we were out to dinner and like we
saw somebody wearing some Teddy fresh
what a cool experience
but we were meeting for your birthday
yeah
at an escape room and we saw something
we went for dinner afterwards and some
dude at the bar was just rocking the
Teddy Fresh hat and me and his dream
from the beginning was like we want to
just run into someone well actually our
dream is to run into someone on the
street yeah we're halfway there
this guy was a fan but still it was
really cool yeah that's awesome and
that's like our dream with the box is to
see someone wearing one of the t-shirts
in it right it has no idea who the heck
any of us are really love it for what it
is yeah so we're trying to figure out
more things we can do with that I'm
trying to figure out how I can grow
vsauce3 outside of just youtube you do
kind of feel pigeon-holed sometimes like
I needed only make these kind of van
it's too unreliable we had like a
existential crisis when the apocalypse
happened and I mean the fashion thing
was something we always wanted to do
anyway and so I I wasn't just helped us
push yeah you know yeah that thing I'm
just so happy that ela is like following
her passion and that's just something
that was in her book that was the first
thing that she wanted to do before we
ever made YouTube so able to go back
that's oscillation 'old ream and be able
to fulfill it I never got into fashion
schools
she was rejected suck in fashion school
I have a successful brand I'm a mom
that's means like the clothing is
legitimately incredible like I love it
my girlfriend super jealous she's like
oh can I wear no oh what does she want
maybe just like a burlap sack she always
wants to wear it but I wear smalls and
she wears normal human being sizes small
it's hard to rock me it's really yeah
and I always have smallest leftover yeah
I'm just like it's got a human skill I
mean we're all skeletons but I have very
little things besides my bones that
surprised me because you are famous for
enjoying of pizza and tacos but yeah
you're such a petite little fella
it's also my diet I don't eat like
breakfast or lunch I just need dinner I
like pineapple you eat one meal a day
I like a pineapple me really a Clif Bar
then at dinner I go hog-wild
like last night I had not chosen a
burrito no one had night before what
come from where I not chosen a buried
beautiful also couldn't I don't think I
could eat one meal a day
I have cravings I have needs see you
just gotta fight through it are you so
tell me how does it work are you
actually hungry but you're like I don't
I don't see I'm always like the thing is
when I eat into it I get very slow like
my thinking gets slow and I can't like
talk as well and I don't just like you
late as well close you down you gotta
eat so is is not cuz that's funny cuz
Austin posts Malone does the same thing
and it drives me crazy whenever we hang
out with him for like a full day I get
so hungry and he's like bro no no like
we're drinking all day usually and he's
like no no at 3:00 a.m. and I can't wait
til 3:00 and the heat it's insane is
that part of like a diet regimen for no
no it's just that like I if I ever have
meetings I have to film I never eat
beforehand because it will slow me down
I won't think as well
interesting what happens to me a lot I
just get too busy and too distracted and
then I'm like wait I'm starving and I
did about the difference between me and
you guys I never forget about food like
before coming here we ordered Michael
really wanted some subs so Michael a guy
I like what a sweetie ordered sweater if
I was here eating editing this I'd be
like I wish man god I wish I had that
because like dude I'm I think I'm at my
happiest when I'm eating nachos let me
show you these photos these sweet nachos
let me see the nachos I have a plate of
beautiful nachos dumped with salsa or a
burger
look at those not just even is that from
a local joint yeah even gave me a side
of nacho cheese but like it's been
having a fat guy disease because like
simultaneously I hate being overweight
and I really want to change but equally
as compelling or I mean looking at me
more compelling is that I watch shows
every [ __ ] day it's it's twisted man
well let me let me throw a and also I
don't want to exercise everybody at home
like whatever ball go on there like a
treadmill because I don't want it that
was gonna kind of busy I love have you
tried one thing I enjoy is do you want
to see the nachos I don't know I feel
bad that I'm not sure you know you
doesn't care about food side of nacho
cheese it's great
oh some refried beans up in there what
are you doing oh okay I didn't took me a
second are you putting that into your
urethra it's fine don't you know what
you're talking about
can you imagine if your urethra was wide
enough to be able to like fitness and
how clean it would be some people are
into that like him oh yeah I've seen
when people shoved thing up there you
reatha a fetish I don't know
Oh Ian can you find out the specific
name of that so everyone watching can go
yeah go google dancing now don't don't
I'm just making a joke no I'm I'm
curious to me that seems to be one of
the most insane fetishes of shoving
things up your [ __ ] that's an out
hole here's for sure well but people
like showing things in other holes that
are generally for out that one
specifically oh it's called sounding I
mean sounding like besides your mouth
what other hole on your body is meant
for things to go in it not the penis
hole I'm never gonna make fun of little
people for the things that they enjoy as
long as they don't hurt okay fine okay
you're into some weird [ __ ] I'm good I'm
not saying okay I'm gay I'm not gonna
stop I'm not judging my urethra you know
what whatever but I would get into it
whatever you're into
god bless you I sang a lot of people in
the chat knew the name immediately to me
I'm disappointed that I wasn't quick on
the sound my sounding that makes it
worse it's like like it's like listening
to it like yeah do you remember this is
old internet days okay stop
you remember grow up would you do you
remember there was a video that maybe
some folks had seen I have two videos
for you maybe we can find him
Ian yeah oh yeah maybe do fine pull
these up you can find anything um Ian I
want you to pull up a video sounding I
don't want to video it was a guy cutting
off his pain Olympics penis yes
I mean it's fake you think we cut off
with that hat of the axe so it matches
first of all I've seen it and I was so
traumatized by like as maturing through
my life
yeah the be any pain Olympics that's it
yes and um well for those of you who
don't know any I'll tell you it's
basically men disfiguring their genitals
you know so like for kaya it's the most
twisted [ __ ] on the planet so like just
a guy would put his dick on a chopping
blocks and just literally hatchet it off
but I'll just say
but it's like Jen can only do that once
yeah it's a one-shot go that's why it's
so special you so that baby back on good
as new like a lizard no they made sure
that you use like a serrated edge I
could imagine to being more difficult to
attach um there's another oh sorry you
go what what are the things that I've
heard since just so everyone watching
knows and especially the the ad policy
team that it was fake it wasn't real and
even if it was real that made me feel
better and so I choose to believe that
it was fake so okay got one more video
for you they might have seen this was
back in the day when like how did that
make you feel because you just glossed
past that and it loved the real impact
on me that was fine so I had a weird
child what was the point of bringing it
I don't remember I don't even know where
I am
no so when I was a kid growing up my mom
really want me to be a doctor so we go
to the library and she would rent just
VHS atop VHS of surgery videos remember
when I watch was like a multi-part three
tape series of this kid getting his fate
like a facial reconstruction interesting
like broke his face and like peeled off
the skin I just watched those in the
basement so I was like you're gonna be a
doctor
wow that's a weird one yeah so to me was
like okay it's the human anatomy I I did
was like oh I don't want that happened
to my wee-wee but I was wait did you see
well okay so this is the other thing I
wanted to talk about it doesn't involve
a wee-wee really at all so back in the
day you know when we had Napster and
Shazam and like imesh you would download
something thinking it was one thing it
would be something else
yep so when I downloaded was these two
Asian women I believe they were Japanese
and they had a lot of ills and I'm gonna
be SPG as possible so this I've seen it
has the funnel then had one girls but
when she's putting the eels into her but
then takes about but you can see through
and we use the the scientific of the
anus you can see the the eels moving and
then they shoot out into the other
girl's mouth she like chews them up and
then like regurgitates them into the
girl's mouth that had them in her but I
never watch that be like huh
I'm not interested in this and that's
when I realized that I was looking
normal nothing you're not normal that's
fine doesn't hurt other people by
Kiehl's
yeah there was a lot of eels that were
murdered for
my god anywhere the darkest days the
days of Napster and Kazaam Jesus
sometimes wakes up from those were the
absolute darkest days those of you who
grew up with Napster and Kazaam stuff
know that pure debauchery that we all
dance I know what I'm talking yeah
you'll get murdered and I'll be like oh
cool this is a chest like animal house
nope someone getting shot in the face
none you just dude wasn't Animal House
at all those were the darkest days bro
that's all I'll say and everybody who's
been there knows exact what I'm talking
about and also like I'm such a
disappointment because we're rocking
like 56k modems here exactly so it took
like ten years for me to download Jason
ten you know the latest prize anyway and
then I find out it's not Jason ten at
all it's a looks Asian lady pooping out
squid squids I wish it was squids at
least have an emotional connection to
them heals it happened to me where I
wouldn't download like him a movie for a
whole week and then it's not that but I
never got like weird you ever get the
one or it's Bill Clinton be like I have
not kids that woman down good no www dot
free sock like they would dupe you and
then actually put in an ad oh really
anyone out anyone relate who can relate
I don't know buddy I'm Dan can you
relate anyway sorry what were you
talking about I think you had you had
like questions with I don't know I I
apologize for getting us this oh we were
talking about sticking things in your
urethra yes sounding we can talk about
something else I mean we don't have to
if it sounds like everyone out there
really enjoys this topic Oh what are you
cleaning a pipe I better be more Wow
let's move on like them it's hard to
really move that like anything else we
had a moment we had an experience I feel
like we're all closer I wish this table
wasn't between I sound doesn't fit on
there I almost I can't even you know
like there was a Girish calm or
something
Audra show rich I think we're just like
I remember that watch one video a guy
his arm that ripped off by a machine
like in a factory I can't stomach that
stuff I saw one mean either we're
watching FIFA that's where they have
like really twist
yeah and we were going through and it
was all real intriguing until we hit one
video of a woman in a stiletto stepping
on a dude's dick it's a fetish she's in
but the stiletto breaks through how goes
through and then he's like he's into it
and then he's like well you can imagine
you've never touched a computer ever
again I don't think we've been but
imagine how much more quickly you could
urinate yeah it's like multiple holes
like a pokin holes like water everything
based on his reaction he wasn't thinking
about that he's now he's ago this is
know what a treat how do you fix that I
wonder if that's a fix about that sir
you have a giant hole in your penis yeah
just going to the hospital like uh so
listen don't ask me how this happened
right just have a hole in my penis art
Seinfeld the macaroni up death I don't
know
when George's dad falls on a macaroni
statue of this and the doctors like I
don't want to know
jackass I think the first movie where he
stuck a toy car but yeah I fell like how
did you that was possible that's
wonderful please let's continue let's
attempt your videos are insanely well
produced and research what is your
process for making new videos like how
long does it take you generally no but
seriously you like you don't post that
frequently mm-hmm and they are extremely
well researched and produced and I mean
you don't have do you have a background
in science and technology and it all at
all really so you are self-taught and
these things like what's the process
when you when you get an idea you're
like all right awesome I'm gonna do
parasites
yeah so tell me tell me how did you get
the idea for parasites and then how did
you start researching it sometimes I've
been interested in because I've always
loved the movie the thing like some of
my favorite films
so always been curious about it and then
again I was I was in it's this rut where
I couldn't really think of anything and
I've I heard his song on the music
library that sounded like John
Carpenter's like score for the thing
interested in and then was like oh wait
okay I could make some of this nice
getting ideas in my head Senna was
really just I just google search
parasites and I find a bunch of
different sources and books and I just
read for that one took about a month I
just read like three books found a bunch
of different studies and research
articles and papers on the internet and
just read everything and then I write
like my notes pages are usually about 10
to 12 pages just notes excluding like my
highlights from the books and then I
condense all that into a script that's
like three pages maybe and it has to
have a narrative flow so like what I'm
what I actually have all my notes I kind
of start deleting things or reorganizing
things depending on what narrative
structure I want and then from there
it's really I find my soundtrack I
listen to all the music and like hey
this song fits for this section I'm
talking about this kind of parasite and
then I just go and film it I find it so
interesting that you start with the
music first my mind doesn't work that
way at all yeah interesting not as notes
your process like sound is the last
thing that we would do yes I would even
it to consider that and like as a part
of the narrative really it's more like
yeah after the fact I mean generally it
just starts with finding a video that is
inspiring or in some way yeah and then
well for the longest time we wouldn't
prepare at all which was great in the
beginning because it had kind of this
magic quality was just everything was
improvised off-the-cuff yeah and it
really had a great quality to it because
it was just so wrong but after like a
year of doing that it just because it's
not sustainable
right you need like more structure yeah
you kind of milk yourself and all your
natural reactions yeah you start kind of
depending on them over and over and then
you just become kind of like a jukebox
and it was getting like really talk
about like creative uh dry a dry well we
were just it was it was getting real bad
and we were like shoot and shoot and
shoot and be shitty shitty shitty now I
feel worse and worse and worse and so we
started now a little more sustainable
just you find the video because if part
of the magic for what us was like we
didn't want to watch it because I wanted
to go in virgin yeah but it's just not
sustainable so we we we don't really
write a script just like planned beats
or we kind of identify the parts that I
want to talk about smart get some idea
of what I want to say
and so just a very real simple roadmap I
would say yeah but a lot of the
mastering of the video comes after we've
already shot it like sketch ideas edits
music everything usually comes in post
mm-hmm yeah it's totally the opposite
were like yeah everything's planned out
like when I fill it I know exactly how
it's going to be cut together like
editing is probably the easiest part for
me because everything's shot how it's
going to be editing has always been the
most grueling Mart for us but I also
think I love editing the most almost
even more than shooting I I don't know
why I hate shooting itself generally
probably because we're so unorganized
hmm and then the editing itself is when
I feel like okay got the footage yeah
now you can take your time and actually
craft it like shape it into what you
want yeah yeah that's interesting but it
makes sense to me with your videos the
music is always like a really big part
of it so lose the motivation like it
helps dictate how the whole story gets
pushed forward are you a musical guy do
you play music well how okay I do not
eat food no I never need to eat I have
water
I have vape I'm eating nachos tonight
yeah absolutely eating myself okay I'm
actually gonna get not just tonight to
[ __ ] and a burrito
hey you know what are you serious you
can do that okay even if I didn't eat
all day and I'm super hungry I can't fit
all that food like I'll be it's because
I hate myself
and I see from the controversial there's
people with like Crohn's disease which
is a terrible disease that I wouldn't
wish on anyone everyone has it it's an
awful thing that won't wish on anyone
but but do you think I have somewhere
but you [ __ ] a lot me you know I'm not
saying you have Crohn's people with
Crohn's [ __ ] a lot you get when I'm at
getting yeah I guess actually oh you can
eat more and pay less just to make you
feel guilty
my I wish I had first girlfriend ever
had died last year of Crohn's disease
what you can dive Crohn's disease well
she also said it's but that was part of
what you later like she had a bag and
all this no I don't want Crohn's disease
anymore I thought it was just you shed a
little bit and eat lots of nachos
god I don't know anything um but and is
your girl good I'll try to make you feel
guilty
oh she's not dead I don't know I've
never been with one um grinder with
anyone besides eels except the notches
in the nachos in the UH okay sorry what
were we talking weird to everyone I hope
everyone tonight's getting nachos who's
watching they're like damn I need [ __ ]
not get some nachos and okay so little
sign no nachos
this isn't branded at all but Chili's
bar and grill has on my favor because
every chip there's no dry chip yeah I
love it it's like ten chips and you're
like oh please attend chip nacho platter
but wait perfectly layered of with beans
it's like each chip is a masterpiece it
is more perfect because like when you
get nachos a giant pile which are nice
you get to the bottom now it's just
chips and they're soggy what am I gonna
do with this I said if you're sharing it
someone else is gonna get all their
goodbye oh yeah they give that one ship
that's connected from that's maybe
that's why you don't like food I wasn't
making a video with smoke with a Neil
smoke deGrasse Tyson about time you guys
talked about and may I ask did you guys
smoke the grass there was no there was
no grass smoking it was really nice I
mean I've I met him a few times we've
done a few things together and it was
just really it was really cash you know
real nice were actually potentially
doing another thing in a few weeks
Oh together when I'm back in New York I
want to meet him I'm on h3 podcast yeah
god I'm trying we reach out we are like
clubs we have to reach through the like
email you got Saget if you can get sag
Tyson this this yep yep but yeah he's
lovely and those that those kind of
videos are the easiest to me because I
don't have to do anything and then turn
into a video yeah which is really nice
is that do you wonder if like that's how
a lot of other youtubers make every
video mm-hmm isn't that cool for them it
is the other thing I because people are
gods and this isn't real content people
watch it so it is like if people enjoy
it say that
but I mean like for other things I'm
sure people say it about me too but like
sure I I just I again it might not be
what I like what if other people like it
cool no I wish I could do that kind of
good on them for finding did my dream is
to find a format that's easy to produce
and the people like as much as the
videos we make that take us more Europe
and that incredibly difficult to do yeah
it's yeah yeah it was easy I think that
there is no such thing actually because
I feel like everything becomes hard like
if you're doing vlogs that's really hard
yeah if you're doing I don't know it
does there is and I have someone on my
mind but I'm not gonna say it because I
don't like in front of people but there
are some creators who have definitely
like farmed it out just like everyone
they just basically show up and host
which is great I shouldn't like that
isn't a bad thing if you get to that
level where you can cool you know like I
know with you guys especially with the
videos that you make on YouTube it's
just pretty much you guys really like
with Vsauce with for Michael and Kevin
and I like Michael and I don't have a
research assistant anything like we do
everything ourselves then we have Eric
you guys know that guys yeah yeah who
does like all our graphics and
cinematography and that's it like for
when it comes to our videos that's what
we have our teams are very very small
because it needs to still be I'm not at
that point yet where I can like give it
to someone else I don't trust anyone
besides myself yeah sure maybe I will
but it's also important to me that it be
what I want that it is like that version
of me that I get to share with others I
don't want to dilute that at all Eric is
an interesting guy he's at the fifth
Beatle like this guy is secret sauce
yeah in a way like he works with all you
guys mm-hmm he's pretty because he holds
this insane camera oh yeah so he's a
camera op which is really hard because
it's super heavy he does cinematography
he edit does he editor he makes all
these crazies oh gosh yeah cuz like
Michael really uses these really insane
graphs and moving pieces he makes all
that Muslim Michael's someone stuff
Michael make himself with everything
that's like 3d generated is Erik and
especially with Michael's videos Michael
bit okay now you need to create
something that no one has ever made
before right so go do that he's like
okay it's incredible what that guy does
she make does he who makes the music so
we have two sources one of this guy is
this guy
chut now that worked at Google with us a
lot of like all of the really when you
hear that drop thing like every song you
think of Vsauce that's like shut now
we've been using him forever soon like
the typical Vsauce music is jut now and
then we use a music library for
everything else now it is both like the
YouTube one oh no no no no audio Network
comm audio network that sounds like a
audio jungle and yeah but they have a
great library like basically all the
music I use nowadays videos I don't know
we have a nice deal with them where we
just have like a blanket license for all
of our channels well it's maybe like a
couple thousand dollars a year but we've
had much music as we want but it's like
music is so important no you're right I
always really like the music in your
videos well thank you yeah it's great
and your latest video was so good Oh
Frank I'll watch it and smash that like
but was the newest one it was the yeah
which tells you everything you didn't
know go watch it y'all seriously that
you've been on fire your I loved your
your most all of your recent videos have
been great oh thank you you know excited
like I think the NEX one's gonna be
little bit different cuz it's really
just gonna be like showing you shapes
and how they work in like perception but
I don't know my dream is always to make
little movies but those cost money oh
yeah that's really good but even if it's
just just but even it's like a thousand
dollars that's like Act is it worth it
is it worth to spend a thousand dollars
to make this video yeah it's always hard
it's like I love those opportunities but
I'm sorry I love the challenge of making
things for cheap like the parasite video
seems like a very expensive video yeah
most expensive thing was Eric and I
flying to Colorado that was like the
most expensive Ford you find that Shack
that was just like an Airbnb you can
Airbnb that little shack like 100 bucks
a night we use it for one night cause
100 dollars ah did you sleep there oh
yeah it was incredibly cold I was the
worst air B&B what were the reviews on
that it was oh it was lovely it was just
like it is what degrees Fahrenheit
outside yeah we had to do everything
like with a fireplace in there that's in
trouble because that looks like pretty
like it looked budgeted but I guess what
you've got the drone you got a nice
camera you just go to this cabin who
knows of nowhere you just make it really
when you show in the latest video how
the editing makes it look like so much
more yes
blissfully this challenge of like
okay remember we were doing it I was
like okay Eric we're gonna have all
these things in the in the shot can you
just like delete them yeah it's like
great and that makes it look so much
better we added mountains to make it
look like we were more secluded uh-huh
there's all these little tricks that
like this record us online to learn how
to do them and you just use that to
emphasize what you're trying to create
which i think is why it's so at least
for my cond it's so important to have a
structure because when I read it I know
exactly how I wanted to look so I know
already and I can talk to Eric about how
we're going to do that and he's like
okay yeah we can do this too yes got it
that's so cool so yeah I like it good
work Eric I know Eric's watching
actually Chris I know I have to call him
out a little bit
I was like do you want to come to the
podcast with me yeah I'd love to and
then this morning is like no I don't
wanna go anymore
oh wow you know what Eric I thought
you're a cool dude I thought we were
like pals in the Tesla you're dead to us
Eric you got to return the tells yeah no
that guy's amazing shout out to shout
out to him I was curious because the
parasites video gave me the creeps
mmm that [ __ ] made me very uncomfortable
was there any like creepy disturbing
stuff you read that you didn't put in in
in the video because I mean there's some
things I didn't put in there's like a
was it Toxoplasma Toxoplasma deep way
what's the deal with with that that's
the one you get from cats yeah that one
come on there have been studies nothing
conclusive which write and put it in
there haven't studies that it might lead
or might enable people who do have a
tendency towards schizophrenia to just
become schizophrenic not cool so it's
things like that like it's always
basically the it's the parasite that
most people have so and for people don't
know this is a parasite you get from
cats that apparently 50% of Americans
are infected with yeah because what it
does the the reason it kind of exists is
that uh it's in the feces of cats and
then like it gets into rats or mice and
then now they're a lot less scared of
cats and they kind of like go over to
them because I believe it's it kind of
changes the the scent profile of urine
first so they don't smell cat you're
like oh that smells like someone heat
I'm gonna go get that and then they get
murdered and die what's the
what's the purpose of of make it's
always self continuation right because
then the new cat the the mouse try the
cat eats the mouse or the rat and then
it gets the parasite again so maybe it's
an uninfected one and it's the thing
that's so interesting about parasites is
that a lot of their purpose is
self-preservation it's to extend their
lifecycle their lifecycle exists within
depending on the parasite within
multiple creatures mm-hmm
so like if it's in me it might not be
the last place that it goes and it's
like isn't its final form so it's this
very interesting and the the thing that
I loved which I kind of end with
spoilers is like how do you know if you
have one or don't if their job is to
survive then would they ever make their
presence known really there could be
ones in us that we just don't know about
right the one that I almost couldn't
watch was the cockroach mm with the
jewel wasp yeah yeah that one's not like
it's like it's so much like the movie
alien there's no just gonna burst out of
your chest it's gonna eat you ha ha but
you did this yourself because in his
mind it's like I'm doing this this is my
decision it's not like how do you know
that your actions are your own all right
talked about sounding we've talked about
parasites take infecting half the
population do this one talked about
Grindr I'm good thank you very much it's
mango flavor is it mango Dan beeps the
office I'm or vaping right now dan is a
fat Ripper dude any rips - unicorn milk
- what flavor you have in there mango oh
just okay I wasn't sure if it was like
unicorn jizz mango because mango is
quite boring more I don't know I just
went to the store and the guy was like
oh try this one is great that's it okay
thank you guy at the store right how is
it
it's nice good it's nice I like it
because you know it's healthier than
than smoking the brown as you call it
the cigarettes you smoke cigarettes I
guess people don't know that about you
well let me um I guess this is ah okay
so so a little back story after so I had
cancer blah blah blah um as you do and
then a year after after treatment all
this stuff I remember the doctor was
like
cancer-free and I was like the first
time
that I cried during the whole thing uh
and is a huge relief but then I started
thinking and I was really pissed off
honestly because I didn't I wasn't like
a bad person didn't smoke cigarettes I
wasn't like drinking all the time doing
all these crazy things was just a
complete mutation too random thing that
happened that wasn't hereditary so it's
good like you know what screw this man
like I've been he'll feed my entire life
I'm just gonna smoke cigarettes because
what the heck that's so you had no
impulse to smoke before no it was just
like [ __ ] god yeah me this [ __ ] I didn't
do anything wrong smoke cigarettes no so
I started doing that for a little bit
and then I was like you know what I
really don't want cancer again I felt it
felt unfair to me huh it is unfair I was
like you know what I'm gonna live my
life a little bit and now I decided to
not do that because it's stupid now
let's fade because also smoking
cigarettes makes you feel like garbage
has a high chance of getting you know
something like it's enjoy the experience
is enjoyable but there's literally
nothing beneficial about it like on a
health level it does like I can reduce
stress it makes you feel nice so you
have that moment but you know what this
basically gives me the same sensation
and I'm not gonna die immediately people
debate if it actually releases stress
people say you create a need to release
stress you become addicted right because
that there was no need to reduce stress
but then once you've been smoking for a
while you get addicted to the habit and
the actual addiction so people mistake
themselves in thinking like oh my have a
cigarette it reduces stress but they're
only addressing the problem they created
what I like about working which if I
worked in like a normal kind of job I
guess would be a better benefit but when
people smoke it's the only kind of
activity we can go I'm gonna go sign
have a cigarette just leave for 10
minutes you're like hey boss I'm gonna
go dick off outside four times like no
you have to work but you have a
cigarette thing of course of course go
smoke that's fine in the army almost
everyone smokes and I think that's why
everyone wants to take a break all the
time yeah and it's really bonding you
all would go together yeah you do it so
bad for you dude either you still
chimney big-time when we met don't tell
me well or you just been outed
yellow smoke the hardcore ones they had
like this [ __ ] like no filter no not
those were gnarly man
we like rolling your everyone in the
army smoke these really cheap super
heavy-duty ones just cuz they were cheap
yeah but they I remember smoking one of
those and I was like I was never really
a smoker though I never like needed it
just wanted to do it yeah I want to join
everyone I was just reminiscing on this
him this collab we did mm-hmm and just
talking about how how we script
versatile you script because when I had
the duty in this video here let me play
it to do like one simple little line man
I didn't think was gonna do it I'm Ethan
and what you're looking at is an
interpretation laundry on I've ever
drawn others the software converts into
a visual representation of the moments
captured it's data and data can be
corrupted great that took like a hundred
tries we were there for so long
affected I'm not gonna be able to
remember this everyone's gonna go home
it's gonna be super awkward and you guys
were on like you guys were like in a
hurry
I remember we had something to do you're
like well if we can't get it by 1:30
we'll just have to come back and do it
on Monday I was like oh my god like you
memorize that whole piece I don't know I
feel like other people are better at it
like elos just like oh yeah this is no
problem
I can't I don't know my memories you're
kind of this like sick too and I feel
like there's something there that you
have more of a bond than usual I'm
disabled no but it's like I I think he
did a great job
and I was really excited that both you
guys were in it I enjoyed it so thank
you no you're great Hey
there was actually certain that's I'm
gonna turn to brag but I just thought up
there there was a video that he would
Jack Black yeah oh I remember he was
like reading over the script with me and
he's somebody monologues he's like oh
you memorize all this it's pretty
impressive and I was like no but I was
looking of course I do
oh I remember when Robert Downey jr. had
my memorized monologues in a second
but he was really gonna write like I had
a whole thing
to do and within five minutes he doesn't
do it Wow I mean I guess do you get
better at that or are you just good no I
think you get better it's like anything
you know yeah I honestly have no
practice really because like I said
that's just not how we shoot our videos
but I did it and when I got it we
everyone was just like yo he cuz capable
of remembering eight words I believe if
I remember correctly you ripped off your
shirt I don't know why the shirt budget
so many shirts you know it's funny
though I do say this about Teddy fresh
it's just an elaborate ploy from ela to
get me to dress better I think it's
working I think that's really fresh
I never thought about it like that but I
was the sweat the tracksuit yeah I was
gonna wear that today again I'd had this
whole thing which I kind of feel guilty
about now but I was like oh is it kind
of like wearing your own shirt like
performing as a band like going on stage
we're like your own blink-182 nghymru
blink-182 shirt I don't know like seemed
like too much of a fanboy that's okay
it would have been it's good either way
I just felt I felt guilty about because
I saw like everyone out there is wearing
tiny oppression we know you rocked that
merch bro I feel like I'm wearing it all
the time so every photo of me just has
it on it's awesome so good I just enjoy
wearing it teddy fresh come for all of
your clothing needs yes let me ask you
this yes let's get you ask all of our
guests this at the bottom of the show
okay
it's okay if you don't have one yep
because not everyone does I don't do you
have any ghost stories or paranormal
experiences UFO visitations alien
visitations anal probes sounding that
alien sound you did you see a ghost
whatever happened have you had an
experience like that super specific an
alien did sound me one have you ever
been found
I've been rusty trombone by an alien his
name was Michael it was really weird
[Laughter]
what is vsauce you got me again
um no so yes I have
experiences with these things when I was
a young boy about five years old I was
setting up Halloween decorations and a
UFO flew over our house like and there
was a forest across the street like flew
over the forest I saw it and I wouldn't
did other people see it I wouldn't was
like my mom it was gone at that point my
mother actually believes that she has
been abducted what she's a strong
believer and she would sleep with my dad
to be out of town she would sleep with a
knife under her pillow
whoa she thought that maybe the aliens
would come back oh and take it
Holy Smoke since she always would be
like I felt like there was a presence in
the room wasn't so can I ask can I ask
how do you corroborate those paranormal
experiences because you're very
scientific and logical person how do you
corroborate those two experiences I
think well when I was five is my memory
could be hazy like our memory works that
every time I remember I mentioned a VHS
tape when you remember it you're
remembering the last time that you
remembered it so there's little
inconsistencies in consistencies things
changed Tecopa the same way that a VHS
tape will deteriorate the more that you
watch it
that kind of happens so who knows if I
actually did I think that I did but I
don't know if I did I strongly believe
when people see UFOs that it's just some
military plane or something like that
because I mean there's a lot of issues
and it's not a shooting couple space
travel I think that the naeli would like
come here um but who knows they might I
do believe that we're not alone in the
universe but I find it hard to believe
that they were able to get to us at any
point in time really I agree because
unless they are so advanced they like
travel near the speed of light in which
case even if they could by the time they
got home time still is the same for
their home planet cool we're gonna
travel this distance so it's gonna take
twenty thousand years on our planet but
for us because we're traveling this
Musil gonna be twenty years right time
they get back it's gonna be 40 thousand
years later everyone's dead um anyway
sorry when it comes to ghosts and things
I do remember one moment was Christmas
morning and I woke up and I went into
the living room where the Christmas tree
wasn't as pitch-black was like four or
five in the morning and I saw my brother
in the corner and his back was to me and
there was like this weird fog around him
and I went over to me I was like Adam
Adam what are you doing up and he turned
around he just didn't think had a giant
mouth as a face
now if this was real or just a dream I
don't remember
anymore how old were you I was probably
like five or six I did you react I like
ran back in that room here for you it
was I had these things were like I was
in my bed laying I saw a shadow but who
knows even over my true imagination I
don't really know I also don't believe
it goes really I have a lot of personal
theories about that stuff I don't think
goes surreal I think if anything this
isn't I'm gonna get I'm not I'm not like
a big spiritual kind of guy but I do
think if anything when we see these
aberrations that if that they might be
just beings of a higher consciousness
because we think about it at some point
you no longer you don't need a physical
form if you're just like pure energy or
like you know everything like if you can
actually conceive of what is nothing
then maybe you don't even need a form
mmm so maybe that's what we see and what
we cuz I was like to think about alien
worlds that we understand what things
are because we have a very geometrical
idea of everything like everything is a
shape right you have a certain form and
your form is created by lines so we're
gonna see something it didn't fit within
that construct we would have to put it
in that to be able to actually see it
right right just the same way that we
can't see like dark matter we can't see
the spectrums of light or color maybe
there's certain things that we just
can't see and we don't know how is it or
take that classic experiment with 2d
world right or if a three-dimensional
creature goes into flat world it would
just appear as us this life because
that's like you just can't comprehend it
you can't yeah how do you visualize it
that's interesting so that to me is kind
of maybe that's what it is maybe it's
just there's cuz there could be other
things wrong there's so much that we
don't see that maybe we hit a little
thing that throws me off about ghosts is
that it seems to be happening to the
same people like you either
I feel like 50% of people are like I've
never seen a ghost
and I want to or but I've just I've
never had it and then the other 50% is
like I see goes all the time well my
counter to ghosts would always be why
don't we see the ghosts of animals like
why are there no animal ghosts mm-hmm
why are they just showing around why do
we only see people like specific people
right like sure there just be ghosts
everywhere yeah all over there's more
people that have died than have been
alive like should we just see ghosts all
over the place so is I'm very skeptical
I mean I don't want to I'm gonna be from
like 1950 like Genghis Khan like the
1800s yeah we don't see like
caveman walking around or cavewoman that
would be cool
or KVA but whatever you want yes um just
smoking the cannabis people he gave
people of cave K board so I don't know I
don't ever want to dismiss something
immediately because who knows right you
know like we find out things all the
time we don't even know that what DNA
was until like 70 years ago I agree
about aliens though it seems so I'm with
our current understanding of physics it
seems super unlikely that someone would
go interstellar mm-hmm
to come peep us out well there's also a
lot of again there's so many things we
don't know it could it be that there's a
wormhole we don't know about that they
travel through like you think about
they're a piece of paper let me use a
dollar bill okay so we take time and
let's say like to get from this also in
the movie event horizon which Merlin's
you go from like point A to point B on a
straight lines can take you longer but
if you fold time right yeah then you can
just go right there and then do you have
the time dilation issue if you do that I
don't know I would assume not because
time relation happens from traveling at
speeds Clarett you were near this right
wait so then you zip on through the
galaxy and it's alright baby but also
you have the thing too like there's just
a speed limit to have fast communication
can travel which I I talked about in a
video crackling light we're like I
always love in movies like in Star Trek
they okay like hey home base we're like
the Klingons are attacking send someone
to help us it's like cool that message
will get to them in four years right
you'll be dead everything will be done
by the time they actually get that
message you know it was really cool
answer to that paradox and Ender's Game
they said that and and it was later
confirmed by this thing called coupled
what is it called coupled particles
coupled atoms you know this weird
phenomenon where two particles or atoms
get joined and if you put it on the
other side of space or wherever they
move in sync together regardless of the
space between them and so like
theoretically that could be used for
something like that could be used for
deep space communication wasn't
everything's theoretical but there's I
mean again it could all be
we just don't know because there's so
much more that we had to discover yeah
which i think is because I don't know
I'm excited I would love it would you go
to space if you had like the choice the
option would you go like just like a
one-way trip or one way to Allah day if
someone's like Allah we can send you
tomorrow's but you can never come back
I would not probably not I let's go
we've got the internet
I'll walk if I had nothing going on I
think we've also talked about it before
if I had nothing going on in my life I
would probably think so really if I had
nothing I didn't have you like nothing
like a meaningful relationship or a job
job that I care about I don't know if I
was like desperate yeah you're working
at a cafe or whatever I don't know I'm
not perfectly fine job again say what
job can I say that doesn't offend
someone your know I was working at a
cafe there nobody's offended very sure
that's a finisher
there someone likes that I don't think I
would I just don't think I'm that brave
honestly I'm a coward
hmm I'm definitely a coward I mean I
wouldn't do it by neither not if it's a
one-way trip like what am I gonna learn
what am I gonna I've already experienced
it with someone that be nice right well
you'll go well you go by yourself
okay we can I can bring you can bring
five friends five friends you get some
ice some graham crackers crackers all
right while we talk about I don't want
to do it about my weight I do really
want to go like just I want to stand on
another celestial body like the moon
great I could do that I just want to be
able to be like I always do not
something else besides the earth yeah
that would be yeah like what a treat no
people get to go to space like so few
have actually gone I do really hope that
people go to march in our lifetime and
I'll happily watch that journey from
home I think it'll happen and luckily we
have people like Elon Musk and such that
are just like screw it I'll just do it
yeah that's awesome yeah look I know
that with Richard Branson Bronson
Branson mm-hmm Branson Branson like he's
gonna do I think at the end of the year
like the first space light for people
they like go then I can like go far out
it was like whoa like a commercial yeah
space space vacation or whatever where
you just like go out like oh cool
microgravity boom come back I would
totally love to do that
I'd be brand deal son it's gonna be so
expensive
I wonder what's the price tag on that
probably 100 that we probably a couple
hundred thousand I was saying apparently
you can already do it in like Russia for
like a million really yeah but you have
to go through a lot of training programs
yeah sure when I was at mmm Space Camp
ladies Space Camp and circus camp yeah
you know I do all the camps also went to
animation camp one of the cool camps
they go to you and I have never been to
a cam not been to camp ever
I used to be a camp counselor that's how
into camp I am I was like you know what
I went to this camp but now I'm gonna
work at this camp that's deep I loved it
you know many kids I destroyed in
dodgeball oh that's the life is so many
ting this so many hopes and dreams
crushed by a red ball flying at their
face right it was love I mean I like the
the kids are nice some of them are
Facebook friends with me now but I
always do counselors versus kids cuz I
like to play not fair right and oh the
joy in my eyes I don't know about theirs
anyway sorry aliens ghosts maybe maybe
yeah I don't really know I I don't know
I would love it I don't know anyway
sorry I could go on well I agree I agree
completely also I do think I need to eat
I'm like so mad I you know what I need
to eat some nachos and so with that
let's go eat some nachos I would not
even first of all if you're not
subscribed to vsauce3 why not what the
hell are you doing go get a plate of
nachos but first subscribe to vsauce3 go
get some nachos come back and watch them
Vsauce three videos while you eat nachos
thank you Jake yeah thanks great is a
joy to have you here fun everyone
watching thank you so much for enjoying
your Friday with us it's Friday right
I'm so out next week is gonna be so it's
gonna be a long one but I'm excited I'm
super pumped I hope to see you got have
you guys along for the ride Monday we've
got a special episode planned hope you
guys can join us for that at the usual
time Wednesday is the live live super
live show with post Malone Friday is Bob
Saget
guys I'll see you there I love you
appreciate you can't wait to see you
guys live man it's gonna be a while
thanks for watching and hi from make
sure if you're gonna sound just make
sure to clean - you have to be sanitary
while you're sounding and with that I
say see you guys
[Music]